[Music]
thank you welcome to the data science
hangout hope everybody's having a great
week
if we haven't had the chance to meet at
a hangout before I'm Rachel it's so nice
to meet you let us know if it's your
first time joining if you want to say
hello in the chat so we can all welcome
you in as well
this is our open space to chat about
data Science Leadership questions you're
facing and getting to hear about what's
going on in the world of data across
different Industries and so
if you haven't been here before every
week we feature different data science
leader as my co-host here to help lead
our discussion and answer questions from
you all
so we are all dedicated to making this a
welcoming environment for everybody and
love to hear from everyone no matter
your level of experience or background
or area of work
it is also absolutely okay to just
listen in if you want to
um but there's also three ways you can
ask questions or provide your
perspective too
um so one you can always jump in by
raising your hand on zoom and I'll be
watching out for that too you can put
questions into the zoom chat and feel
free to just put a little star next to
it if you want me to read it
um and I can call on you to introduce
yourself and add some contact otherwise
and then third we have a slido link
where you can ask questions anonymously
and Tyler oh already shared that in the
chat right now
and so we do share the recordings of
each session to the posit YouTube so you
can always go back and re-watch or share
with a friend
but with all of that and welcome
everybody thank you so much for joining
us and thank you so much Nick for
joining us the co-host today Nick
philippew is Chief data officer at Cape
Fear Collective
and Nick I'd love to have you introduce
yourself and maybe start off by sharing
a little bit about your role and also
something you like to do outside of work
sure so um
my name's Nick philippew I'm the chief
State officer at Cape Fear Collective we
are at yep kpr movie people are always
like is it okay if you're like the movie
it is based on uh this is Cape Fear
regions the kind of Southeastern uh
North Carolina uh region kind of
Wilmington if you're familiar with that
area
um
we are non-profit in based out of
Wilmington that's really focused on the
state of North Carolina now
um and we're really looking to use data
to uh move the needle on on these kind
of social impact issues social
determinants of Health
um my background is more in private
sector data science Consulting so I
worked for a couple consultants and was
doing work with Southwest Airlines and
Procter and Gamble and Lowe's and
Baltimore Ravens and Cincinnati Reds and
a bunch of different organizations and
really uh looked at this as an
opportunity to kind of make an impact in
in the state that I that I'm from and
that I love some things that I do
outside data is uh just kind of building
stuff in my yard I'm building a porch uh
now a screened in porch in the back of
my house
um I'm I'm into music and surfing and
just kind of hanging out here and uh
Coastal North Carolina
nice well thank you so much Nick for for
joining us
um and I it's really impressive to to
hear your journey and all the different
types of organizations that you've
worked in
um I know from your bio you were once a
teacher as well and I'm curious to kind
of hear a little bit about that journey
into data science
yeah so um I I did uh get my my
undergraduate I got a undergraduate in
math and math education it was a double
dual major
and taught high school math for a couple
years geometry and AP Statistics and
found myself really every day in class
with these AP Statistics kids kind of
talking to them about here's why
statistics is so cool and here's all the
awesome things you can do with this and
the applications and and realize you
know of course they're like yeah yeah
all right whatever Mr P
um
and really realized that I was talking
myself into going back to grad school so
came home one day and told uh Tomo
office I think I want to go back to
school and get my Master's in data
science so I went back left the
classroom went back to um
uh the NC State Institute for advanced
analytics and got my my Master's Degree
there and then kind of went into the to
the data science world and haven't
really looked back since I still I still
miss teaching sometimes
um but I get to do a lot of teaching in
my leadership roles in my organizations
as well so I've got a lot of Junior devs
and I've got six data scientists on my
team at um at Cape Fear Collective I've
had a number of interns and volunteers
over the the years that I still get to
kind of scratch that itch for for
teaching a little bit just in a you know
outside the classroom
I was just gonna ask you what did that
like teaching look like now within your
organization like helping new new users
learn
yeah um code review
um just kind of uh scaffolding you know
a lot of the the things
um
I like to say that I can teach anybody
to code
what I can't teach people to do is be
curious and kind of think about
uh the kinds of things they should be
asking on a project so a lot of times on
a project especially with a junior Dev
I'm I'm showing them my thought process
I'm thinking out loud and kind of like
you know a lot of times you know they'll
they'll hey I got this error and I can't
figure this out it's like all right
let's screen share it's like all right
first of all what's the error said well
I didn't look at it yet all right well
that's the first thing to do is look at
the error right like because these
things sometimes will tell you exactly
what's wrong sometimes they're not some
of the errors are less intuitive
especially
um you know depending on programming
language but um we are in our shop so we
do a lot of kind of our code review and
and a lot of it's just you know what
you know what do you what are you
expecting it to do is this what you
expected to happen when you wrote this
line of code it's like well no
um you know so so I think uh a lot of it
is just kind of that modeling my thought
process out loud for them to kind of see
here's how someone who's been doing this
for a while thinks about these things
and approaches uh these Solutions
I feel like I have a lot of power here
when I get to ask these questions in the
beginning as we're waiting for them all
to come in but just a reminder to
anybody who just joined you can also use
slido if you want to ask anonymously or
can raise your hand here on Zoom or put
it in the zoom chat
um but Nick something I I wanted to ask
you is
I know you've worked at a few different
Fortune 500 companies and you said
you've been you helped them transform
the way they think about their customer
strategy
um and I would love to learn a little
bit about how you did that I think a lot
of people here in the audience might be
in a position where they're trying to
like get their company to be more data
driven and trying to push new tools
forward so that would be really helpful
yeah sure so
um
as I'm sure y'all have had someone else
tell you or maybe you haven't but you
know a lot of people are fans of analog
analytics and and data science if it's
confirming what they already believe and
one of the things you know working in
pricing and marketing analytics at
Lowe's if I went into a room with a
bunch of people who are marketing Lumber
and I said hey the promotion that you
did last week last uh last week did
really well they're all like yeah all
right we really like this we really like
this guy right if I was like hey you
know but it missed these markets in
these markets then there was a reason
why like no you didn't analyze it right
you didn't do this and you do that so
you know people people like data and
analytics if it confirms their
preconceived uh biases and and beliefs
but if it if it counters that then
that's where they start poking holes and
wanting to
um uh you know kind of kind of find find
fault in it so one thing that I've been
very successful in my career is kind of
starting to build that that trust find
some quick wins what are some small
projects we can work on together that
are low stakes projects that um kind of
gets people to buy into and see like
okay now I can see why there's value in
this this way of thinking
um
so that when that inevitable uh yeah
exactly don't start with forecasting
that's good advice
um
when that inevitable
cognitive dissonance comes then there
you've built up some some trust and some
Capital that with that partner
that's a great Point Patrick I see you
have your hand raised do you want to
jump in
thanks Rachel and uh yeah good morning
everybody uh happy to chat with you
again Nick you and I spoke a couple
years ago
um you may not remember but uh but you
were helpful on a couple of things for
me so I appreciate that and glad to see
you again
uh I'm I'm wondering about uh the
comparison and contrast
um you know similarities as well of
working in those big corporate settings
versus where you are now in non-profit
and you know social services and that
kind of thing personally I've been in
academic and non-profit settings my
whole career and so it seems to me it
seems appealing that uh you know people
really have their things together in a
corporate setting and everything is well
funded and runs smoothly and uh I I
assume you can dispel that myth for me
but I'm just kind of wondering about
your thoughts on that
yeah absolutely and I think you nailed
part of it and and uh Marlene nailed a
part of it here too
um because there's certainly this it is
it is a myth that these large companies
really have
um have everything all put together
because the reality is I I saw some
things in every all these Fortune 500
companies I've worked in I saw things
that would make all of you cringe and
I'm probably not going to say any of
those because I don't want to get myself
in trouble but things that it's just
like I can't believe you run your stack
that way that is not the way up 80
billion dollar company should be running
that uh the this file should not reside
on one person's laptop right that should
be in a shared platform lockdown Etc so
um so there's that one of the biggest
differences though for me is in large
companies people can hide you know like
there's there's kind of uh there's room
your your errors and your kind of weekly
links on your teams don't kind of expose
themselves as as readily as on small
teams on some of the small teams have
been on my previous company was 35
people and currently at kefir Collective
we're a team of 12. and there's no room
for
um somebody to just kind of not not be
pulling their weight
um so I think that's a big difference
um another big difference is I think a
lot of the Fortune 500 companies whether
or not they're actually implementing it
um is another thing but they at least
know that they should be they've heard
enough times through all the Articles
and through the conferences and through
their their leadership like you need to
be doing things data kpis measurements
dashboards Etc they know they need to be
working on it there's some pressure to
kind of do that whereas in the social
space a lot of the stuff's very new and
it's a it's a dramatic cultural shift
um a lot of the non-profits that that we
work with are
um
used to being able to just
and I'm going to kind of say this kind
of tough you know for a minute they're
used to kind of just patting themselves
on the back and saying like we did good
work and that's good enough and the
thing is like for the funders and the
philanthropic uh organizations and
grants that are funding them it's not
good enough anymore you have to be able
to show us that you're moving a needle
which means you have to set some kpis
measure them collect data and and show
that you're making impact against that
or else you're not going to qualify for
that next round of funding we can't just
do feel good funding anymore
foreign
thank you very much for uh for sharing
and offering that perspective
sure
I see a few anonymous questions coming
in on slido and one was can you talk a
little bit about getting your first role
in data science any tips for jumping
from data analytics to data science
sure
um and this whole anal analyst versus
data science thing is such a a weird
ambiguous thing anyways if you ask you
know there's there's people that I know
who call themselves analysts they're
titles analysts and they're programming
in Python and are every day and it's
like that's a data scientist to me uh
and then there's other people who are
like well I'm a I'm an analyst and it's
like well are you a business analyst or
are you uh you know like there's so
titles
titles kind of all uh get kind of get
kind of wonky anyways but for me
you know my getting my first role I
really wanted to be somewhere where I
had
um other folks who could challenge me
that I could learn from I think a
mistake that I see in a lot of young
devs and data scientists is they they go
right to a startup or write to a small
company there's nothing wrong with
either of those I've done I've done both
but you're on an island
um you don't have the support that you
need and and a lot of these
um
I just saw the joke in the chat yeah
that's that's pretty accurate right
there too
um but uh a lot of these larger
companies have support structures in
place there's going to be senior data
scientists senior analysts who who can
help you and know the data sets and can
you know so so find one of those
large companies with a solid structure
latch on to a couple senior devs and be
a sponge right just absorb everything
that you can
um and then the other thing that I can
provide that I always tell people who
are trying to break into the spaces
nobody likes somebody who who pretends
like they know everything because none
of us do right like there's power in
saying I don't know and if you apply for
a job on my team and say that you know
how to do national natural processing
languages and modeling and and I put you
on a project that requires that skill
set and it's obvious that you don't
I don't know like it's you're not
fooling any you're only fooling somebody
uh until it's time for you to use that
skill so be honest about what you know
and and how good you are at it if you
say you're a 10 in R
um I don't even consider myself a 10 and
R so
um you better be really good if you say
that
again yeah Marlene Marlene that point
about like every time I think I'm an
expert or something I think there's a
graph that shows that kind of like the
more you learn about something and then
you hit a point where you're just like
like there have been times in my career
where I'm like I'm an expert Excel
user and then I'll meet somebody that I
work with I'm like wow that I
I'm like a two and then I'll be like
okay I've learned now I'm at like a
seven or eight I'll meet someone else
I'm like level four
you know so definitely uh there's always
someone out there who's better at it
than you
thank you another anonymous question was
any advice for someone working for a
large corporation that's very resistant
to new tools
um to progress in the data science world
yeah
um
brush up your resume now um uh I think
it's a it's a hard thing moving someone
else made the point earlier that you
know Big Ships turn really slowly or
something like that you know and it's
it's true and
um yeah I think
other than just kind of keep keep
beating the drum and keep trying to
prove value
um unfortunately a lot of these these
companies just sometimes it's going to
take way more than you to to get it so
what I do
um or what I recommend to people is when
you're interviewing for that job make
sure the questions that you ask are kind
of hinting at what that data culture is
one of the questions that I think is a
really good question to ask
um is
what is a model or a process that your
team has built that is currently being
used for the company to make decisions
on and you'll be you'll you'll be really
surprised to hear the wide variety of
answers that question gets because
really obvious to hear someone's kind of
like like fumbling like ah we built this
thing but it never got implemented
because of whatever or we've been
working on this thing and for a couple
years and and it's it's never quite
gotten the traction that it needs and
there's gonna be other teams that are
like oh we've got this this thing that's
helping with our you know search engine
optimization and we've got this other
model that's out there that helps
determine you know where we build new uh
locations and and what you hear there is
this is an organization that is putting
their money where their mouth is they're
not only hiring people to build these
models but they're making business
decisions based off that
um so I think yeah I don't really yeah
I'll leave it there
thank you
um just to give us a little bit more
context too on some of the work that
your team does today I thought it might
be helpful to hear a little bit about
the community data platform or maybe
like an example of
a problem your your team is solving
sure so uh one of the problems that we
hear a lot or one of the the kind of
issues that we hear a lot is there's
there's not data for that you know you
have so our organization is really
working to build data capacity across
these non-profits there's 1200
non-profits in New Hanover County and
there's no shortage of passion there
they all think they're doing good work
and and they are
but
um there's no real data capacity to
understand you know what's the value in
generating a hypothesis and measuring
data collecting data
um so what we keep what we always hear
is I would say well hey you've been
doing this thing for 30 years
how's it going how's it working and
they're like well you know people really
like our our food boxes or whatever it's
like okay that's cool uh is it actually
like moving the needle on food
insecurity or or hunger or health issues
in your community they're like well
there's not really data for that I'm
like let's see about that you know so
one of the first things we did is we
pulled in Census Bureau data Bureau of
Labor Statistics CDC fhfa and all these
publicly available data sources that for
us as data scientists are really easy to
grab because we know how to use an API
to go do this we know how to scrape a
website we know how to uh search Google
specific terms that are going to lead us
more successful uh results but for the
average non-profit Community leader they
don't know how to use an API they don't
use Python they don't know any of this
stuff right so for the first time ever
in our community we really have this
holistic 360 degree view of what a
community looks like
um and the way we're using that is to do
things like you've got a non-profit who
wants to do something here we're going
to find a metric that works for you and
and help you build a a mission around
that we are going to decrease children
and concentrated poverty in this
neighborhood by five percent over the
next 10 years and we need
two hundred thousand dollars to do that
or whatever right like that is a
statement that is impossible to make
without understanding how many people
currently live in that situation what
the current projection is for that
neighborhood and kind of like what a
reasonable
decreases for that for that metric
so a lot of our work is really kind of
around that but there's some other
larger projects
um one that I'll talk about I'm actually
going to drop this
uh Link in here is this awesome video
that we just put out it kind of walks
through this but um
uh the Michael Jordan Foundation just
put these two clinics in Wilmington
um Michael Jordan's from Wilmington
and he wanted to put them in areas where
they're going to make the most impact
for low-income marginalized populations
the hospital system said that's great we
know a lot about chronic disease and we
know a lot about health conditions we
know very little about the kind of
social determinants of Health that
you've been studying so help us figure
out from a data perspective
specifically where these clinics are
going to make the most impact
so that's kind of our Flagship
um project and one that we're really
proud of this is North Carolina
yeah that's a great video to check out
too
thank you
um Morris I see you had asked a question
in the chat a bit earlier do you want to
jump in next
yeah thanks no I think he I think he
just kind of answered it
um
harsh at least uh yeah I'm I'm you know
I'm I'm working in a non-profit and I'm
a social work transformation is always
really the big question how do we
measure that how that's what we want we
work we're pretty good at tracking
outputs
uh but the outcomes and uh it's a little
bit more difficult
um so yeah but but those that these are
helpful thank you yeah and that's that's
actually a question that we struggle
with a lot too so I'm glad you brought
that up because a lot of time it's not
fair to say hey food bank it's on you
Food Bank of New Hanover County to lower
to to turn this area into a non-food
desert by yourself right and not only
that but the lag in data is such that
the USDA only classifies these food
deserts every five years so it might be
five ten years before we even know if
you've moved the needle on this kind of
macro metric so what we try to do is we
try to to tie these kind of Micro Data
metrics to those those leading indicator
so we might not know the Census Bureau
data for another two years because of
the lag but what we do to have is this
real-time emergency department data a
real-time police data that we have for
our region and if we can find the
correlation relation between those
things and what we can do is we can say
we can see a signal here at a at a right
now level that we know is tied to this
kind of macro level and then we can kind
of hypothesize that you're moving you're
you're moving the needle at this
um greater level that that you haven't
been able to to measure before
another question that was asked
anonymously a bit earlier was how do
non-profits think about the substantial
costs of a data team are these getting
more common with the trend of needing to
prove moving the needle
uh yeah I mean the the reality is it's
unattainable for the average non-profit
to have a data scientist on staff but
that's that's okay because that's that's
one of the things that that we're hoping
to do because you know part of our
business model is we don't need
um you know
Catholic charity missions of Wilmington
North Carolina it doesn't need a
full-time data scientist all they really
need is 40 hours with somebody on my
team to kind of help kick start the way
they think about about data so instead
of saying
um hey every non-profit in in North
Carolina needs to go hire a data
scientist it's how do we kind of become
that knowledge Hub that that kind of
through contracts through pro bono
contracts over the last three years
we've done 2.8 million dollars in pro
bono data science Consulting so what
that looks like is once somebody on my
team sitting right next to a non-profit
looking at their sales force or looking
at their Excel or downloading their
their data and saying hey did you know
that that you know 15 of your uh clients
are from this neighborhood but the
actually like the majority of the need
in our county is over here and they're
like never really thought about that
it's like Okay cool so maybe like put
some flyers here and let's try to make
sure that like your services are right
like that's something that they've never
really had the ability to do before
because you know turning addresses into
latitude and longitude coordinates and
matching it with Census Bureau data is
Out Of Reach For A lot of them all of
them
how did you start thinking about like
the different data sets that you might
start using it I'm trying to also
Imagine like for people who are working
in a company too there's probably so
much data within their company that they
don't know how to use or where to get
yeah
um I mean if I wish I had a better
answer for it but the reality is I just
started grabbing stuff you know I I like
to say I've never met a data science uh
data set in this space that I didn't
like
um and that's still true even though
we've met some garbage data sets we
still bring it all in because we think
that the kind of the triangulation and
the the whole uh combination of all
these different data sets
um
really adds to the story and I'll give
you kind of an example of this
um we're talking to a hospital in um in
in New Hanover County and I did see a
question about is it just eastern North
Carolina kind of we're kind of across
the state now but we kind of started
there so majority of the work that we do
is still kind of eastern North Carolina
we had a hospital who was looking at
doing some Outreach for covet testing
and the since and they're looking at
kind of where do we need to put the
Spanish Flyers right we've got these
English Flyers we've got tv ads we've
got signs where do we need to put uh
Flyers that are written in Spanish and
you know we told them
well you need to put them here and
they're like well based on this on the
Census Bureau data only like you know
I'm making the numbers up by camera off
top of my head but only like five
percent of the people there are Hispanic
or English Second Language or whatever
and it's like okay that might be true
but for reasons that we don't have to
discuss in this call A lot of times
non-english speakers are are
de-incentivized to fill out the Census
Bureau and actually there's a Fear
Factor there and everything else so uh
the Census Bureau historically
undercounts them number one and then
number two based on your data you have a
large portion of of Spanish-speaking
patients who live in this this area so
there's a mismatch between the Census
Bureau data and the and the hospital
data who's right who's wrong
don't know but it's like if you only had
one of those data sets you might make a
decision that's not actually the right
one so by having them both you have a
more uh complete version of the story
thank you
Elaine I know Nick just answered the
first part of that question but would
love to have you jump in and ask the
the second part
yeah so I'm just I'm curious because it
sounds like you're regionally focused
with this model of
um a combination of contract and pro
bono Central support
how does that work in terms of kind of
getting to know people helping them
identify needs and so on in your mind
versus maybe focusing on
you know a particular type of non-profit
and working in a larger national
International scope
yeah
um
it was really natural for us we had some
really early success in the first year
where people were in in New Hanover
County and that's that kefir region are
like we love this we love it we started
seeing like a
all of a sudden people in Raleigh are
asking us and people in Charlotte are
asking us and we're like are we going to
go Statewide are we going to go Regional
if the whole Southeast North Carolina
are we going to be like Eastern Sea when
does this this stop and and it kind of
auto corrected itself because we kind of
got to the mountains of North Carolina
and people up there all of a sudden were
just like I don't care where you're from
in eastern North Carolina you don't know
anything about us up here right so there
still has to be this kind of boots on
the ground connection to the region or
else for the same reasons we talked
about building uh trust and capital in a
Fortune 500 company if you think about
the state in that same way if if you're
from uh from the beach town and you try
to go up into the mountains and tell
them you know what they don't know about
their Public Health crises you're going
to get run out of there with a stick
right so I mean you still have to to
build these connections organically so
that kind of that's kind of limited our
business plan in a way that I think
makes sense not in a bad way like oh we
can't do that
um now the other thing is we've made it
very clear that we want to work kind of
by width and and through and not around
so areas that already have if there's an
area in North Carolina that has an
organization that does what we do we
definitely don't want to go in there and
say like we're going to we're going to
replace you right it's how do how do we
work together how do we start sharing
some tools
um on some of this work because we you
know we understand that that you're here
we can't there's plenty of work for all
of us anyways so we don't really have
our site set on any sort of
um there's so much work in eastern North
Carolina here's here's a stat for you if
if you carved North Carolina in half
down Highway 95 I-95 and you just looked
at the East part of it and made that a
state it would be the poorest state in
the country
so no Raleigh no Charlotte no
Winston-Salem no Greensboro if you just
looked at the East part of the state it
would be the poorest state in the
country so I mean that's that's the
level of challenge that we're working
with so we have our hands full with just
that uh but definitely are opening our
eyes to kind of the whole state
Bill thanks tangent there did I answer
your question I'm sorry
I think I did
yeah I think that like that aspect of
working with people who trust you and
trust that you know something about
their domain
is a good it's a good point that makes
sense
and it makes me laugh because I know
North Carolina and also makes sense from
that regard
um bill I I think you asked a question
in the chat a bit earlier do you want to
jump in next
and I can
I can read the question for you it was
uh Nick maybe you stated this earlier
but are you using cloud-based resources
or on-prem infrastructure
um and then it the second part is have
you grown your own or do you use posit
or some other service provider
yeah so we're using
um like I said we are in our shop so
we're using our shiny and shiny apps
um the community data platform that we
built is a is a MySQL based product that
is in AWS so we're using S3 so a lot of
the stuff that we're using is is cloud
cloud-based and we just kind of made
that decision early on because it was
um just so much easier to scale it and
cloud storage is so cheap now that it
just doesn't really make any sense
um so uh definitely excited to see about
kind of the changes that come with with
posit and I'm not just saying that
because this is a positive call because
I'm an I'm an R guy I love R I've used
python I've used SAS actually started my
career in SAS
um and quickly uh switched to something
else
but um but yeah
that's what we're using
thank you Marlene uh if you have a
question in the chat too do you want to
jump in
oh sure hi hi Nick hi everyone
um love your talk so far I don't think
there has been a single one I haven't
enjoyed though so I feel repetitive
every time I get a chance to say that
um I I'm always curious
um you're you seem very articulate and
obviously you know your stuff
um with analytics but I'm always curious
is there kind of a skill set or talent
that you think most people wouldn't
associate with analysts kind of like a a
preconceived notion about we're just
nerds that's in cubicles and don't know
how to interact with people right what's
a talent or skill set that you you think
people should probably know like it's
probably handy to have that maybe it
served you well that we wouldn't think
of as analysts and scientists
yeah
um you know I think it's it's gonna
sound cliche but just like listening and
and being able to have a conversation
like I I can't hire robots there's no
there's no position on my team for
robots in these days of of kind of like
we keep the Nerds over there we kind of
like give them their assignment under
the door and don't touch them leave them
alone let them do their thing like those
days are over like there's no space for
somebody who who does that and and most
companies maybe some uh you know very
specific you know Niche Tech spaces
there are but in general like listening
and and and being able to to go back and
and
take feedback and and not be be offended
um because a lot of times you know
there's this I was actually just
laughing at this
um this meme I saw on on LinkedIn where
it was like you know how how people see
a data scientist and a bunch of people
kind of like sneering over at this alien
who's typing in a foreign language and
it was like how data scientists see
everyone else and it's like they're all
like cavemen like uh and they're all
kind of you know Hank waving these clubs
around and there's some truth in that
and it's awful but it's like I there's
been so many times where I've got out of
a meeting and somebody said like
oh well they don't really know what they
want I'm going to build them something
anyways it's like okay that's a route
that you can go that that's a
possibility but like where does that get
you that gets you now you've spent a
whole Sprint making a development that
you know they just said they don't want
and now you're going to be frustrated
and you know double down and say no they
really don't know what they want but
it's really just because she didn't
listen so taking those extra
moments to kind of really listen to what
they're saying and and not and there's a
difference between like listening to the
question they're really asking and like
finding the question you want them to be
asking and what they're saying right and
that's a subtle difference uh that I
think
needs to be made
listening
have you had to coach people on that or
any
tips for us on that
yeah
um definitely had to had to coach some
some people on that um
you know I think a lot of times it's
just I definitely have the management
style of just kind of modeling and
Scaffolding that behavior like it it's
it's I feel like it's easier for people
to learn it if they just kind of see you
interacting with clients in a respectful
way and kind of listening to them and
asking those probing questions
um because you can kind of just say like
hey make sure you're listening to the
client and make sure you're kind of
really asking those probing questions
but like this kind what does that look
like you know
absolutely miles I see you have a
question in the chat you want to jump in
uh sure hey Nick thanks for uh doing
this so when you were talking about uh
the difference between like you know
East Carolina and the coastal Carolina's
and like how do you organically build
those relationships because I feel like
maybe there would be not maybe not
resentment but some sort of like kind of
like standoffishness of like okay this
is a coastal guy he doesn't get it he
doesn't know what's going on so how do
you build that trust in that
relationship
yeah and it's even worse than they when
they find out I live in Raleigh because
I actually grew I grew up in eastern
North Carolina on the coast but now I'm
in Raleigh in the capital so then I'm
I'm talking to some of these small towns
and it's like oh just some guy from Rob
from the capitol from the city telling
us how to do stuff
uh if we ignore him long enough he'll go
away and start bugging somebody else
right
um the same the same way that that we
talked about
um
you know building building capital in a
in a big company you know especially
with with this line of work you'd be
surprised at how much buy-in you can get
if you show up and you actually know how
to pronounce the town name and the
county name correctly if you go into to
you know Beaufort North Carolina and you
say Beaufort that's South Carolina by
the way spelled exactly the same but
it's Beaufort in South Carolina it's
Beaufort in North Carolina if you go
into Beaufort and say and call it
Beaufort you've lost them before the
even the first slides hit the screen
right because it's just some somebody
else from some Outsider coming in here
who knows nothing about us so just being
able to go in there and say and one of
the things that our data scientists data
science team has done is kind of you
know when you're learning about a new
area one of the first tasks that we
started doing is put together a deck of
just kind of I want to know the five
worst areas of poverty in this area I
wonder the five areas where uh there's
employment you know great employment
parity or or great employment rates all
these different things and through that
exploration you kind of be like oh you
kind of understand oh there's this town
here and there's this other town here
and this is this County and you kind of
learn about that area so now when you're
in a conversation you can kind of
intelligently talk about that region it
doesn't sound like you're just some
person looking at a chart and saying
like you need to do this in in this
that's really helped us to really just
learn about the areas that we're working
in
thank you
yeah thank you so much for that Colter
do you want to jump in next
yeah sure thanks
um just a quick background uh I actually
work on the data science team in my
local public health agency and we quite
often help out
um non-profits uh we get tons of
requests hey we need some data but you
know we legally can't get it uh can you
analyze this we want some spatial
analysis
um but I was just thinking how cool it
would be if we had a a local non-profit
with the skill that that your
organization has so I was wondering if
you um if you've ever had a you know
chance to collab with local public
health agencies or academic institutions
and kind of what that relationship was
like
yeah
um and I'm I'm really encouraged to hear
that some of the local governments are
starting to to get that uh that skill
set in-house because I don't think
that's very common so that's that's
awesome to hear that uh we work closely
with a lot of County governments uh City
governments
um
universities definitely UNCW NC State
UNC uh some some folks at Duke and UNC
Charlotte and some others but
um to be honest at first especially the
the the county the local governments are
always all in they're like yes please
help us help us figure this out
um there there's been some kind of
resistance at first from some of the
universities are just kind of like who's
this Plucky little non-profit who's
coming in here and acting like they can
do this this data science work and then
when they kind of see like oh actually
they've got some people on staff who who
have some credentials and some
experience and know what they're doing
then their their tune kind of changes a
little bit but um you know a lot of
times you know one one project we worked
on was
um there's a County
uh in North Carolina that that should be
in uh the MSA that Wilmington's in but
because there's a river between the two
there's a bridge uh it's actually in the
Myrtle Beach MSA so like we did some
work with the Brunswick County uh
government because their thing was look
oh
60 of our people work in in that county
right there you know but we're in this
other MSA in South Carolina who doesn't
care about us we don't get any support
from the funding there so we're kind of
in this weird ambiguous limbo space
where like uh you know how can you help
us make the case to the Census Bureau
that we should be in this MSA so we
compiled all this data and basically
found all these commuting patterns and
you know residency patterns and
everything else that basically showed
you know this belongs in this other
County TBD whether the Census Bureau is
actually going to listen to us because
we haven't got that result yet back but
um but that's kind of an example of one
of those projects that we did
awesome thank you
uh Jamie I see you had asked a question
a bit earlier as well do you want to
jump in next
and thank you all for all these great
questions too
thanks for the opportunity
um you know I think I'm getting the
sense that I may be in the minority and
that data science is not my my primary
work and so I am trying to sort of know
enough to be dangerous about data
science just to interact effectively
with you guys
um and so I'm curious when you sit down
with a client
um like a university
how like what expectations do you set or
what deliverable do you do you talk
about
yeah a lot of times it's just knowledge
knowledge sharing and data sharing at
first it's um hey we'd love to work with
your organization because a lot of times
universities are the path to opening up
greater data access you know the there's
financial institutions for example who
are way more willing to give
um you know UNC Chapel Hill a a big pile
of people's credit card transactions
than they are my team of non-profit data
scientists six six folks uh sitting on
the coast of North Carolina right
um so so a lot of times that
conversation is how can
we've we've got a a gap to fill projects
that are maybe too small for you because
a lot of these universities don't also
want to sit next to you know cause for
pause and and canines for for veterans
and help them not because they don't
want to but because they have bigger
projects they're working out Blue Cross
Blue Shield and other large projects so
we've we're filling a need that you
can't fill
uh but we need resources that you have
so
um we also have a couple projects where
we'll enlist kind of the research arm of
these facilities because
love universities love research love
Academia things move very slowly in the
in the University world and too slowly
for a lot of the organizations that
we're working with
um
so yeah that's that's kind of where we
see that that lane is when it comes down
to doing a longitudinal study we'll kick
it over to you UNCW but right now we
just need to kind of
do some basic analysis
and so you're imagining
sort of
um taking the place of a university
statistician data management
sort of person or you're kind of coming
in with your own project and asking the
university for data
it's usually more the second route like
we gotcha we're not really yeah we're
kind of filling uh so a lot of times you
know all these Counties have to fill out
these Community Health assessments every
year uh or every three years I believe
it is they're mandated by a law to do
these Community Health assessments
um the universities are totally capable
of doing them but
um they kind of bid for them and what
you end up with is like UNC has done
these and NC States done these and ecu's
done these and now it's really hard for
these counties to compare how they're
doing against these other accounts
because this other county has a
completely different format completely
different metrics they focused on so
like one of the things we've we've
pushed on is how how can we help you
align on a common set of metrics so that
when you're doing it or you're doing it
or you're doing it duke or whoever
um we all are at least looking at you're
still going to have room for your own
flavor and your own research and
academics but can we all at least agree
like these 10 metrics will be in every
single report measured the same way
talked about the same way so that it
allows us some level of of knowledge
sharing and comparison like that's
something that that we can a
recommendation we can make as an outside
entity that none of them are going to
make to each other
boy and I I see you shared a um a link
in the chat and just wanted to see if
you wanted to share a bit about what
that is
certainly
um so the census open Innovation lab
which is kind of a subset of the Census
Bureau has been doing a project called
the opportunity project or top for
several years with a partner
um with organizations in order to solve
kind of real world problems with open
data
um it sounds like Cape Fear is really
pushing the boundaries of what can be
done with open data but that would be a
way to kind of interface directly with
government agencies to use the data to
solve problems
um and develop data products to kind of
help local communities they did have a
summit a couple of weeks ago that was
streamed to YouTube that kind of gives
you an idea of what's been done but the
2023 process is getting ready to kick
off in a couple of months so it might be
of interest
oh I hadn't seen that one yet I'm gonna
put it on my list here
Nick I was I remembering that that we
were first talking on like
um about tidy Tuesday and I was curious
if that's something that uh the team is
starting to look at now or if you were
maybe sharing a data for a tiny Tuesday
project and maybe other like open source
initiatives where people could get
involved
yeah so as a user I've done tidy Tuesday
a couple times I think I did one on
uh slave migration one on tennis stars
maybe one on a couple other random
things
um I think it's just such a cool project
to just everyone rally around a data set
and kind of code for for a couple hours
on a Tuesday
um I'm trying to think about how to how
to Wrangle our data platform into
something that would be
not too overwhelming for that because
you know we've got this big SQL database
that has I think it's got a 170 180
tables in it obviously we don't want to
just kind of say like here play around
in this big you know because people will
just get lost so can we can we create
like a CSV that we've kind of joined
three of these tables together and said
like all right you've got food
insecurity social vulnerability index
from the CDC and poverty at a census
track level go what can you do right
um so yeah we're definitely going to put
a submission in uh just kind of how we
provide something that's like the the
right scale for a an activity of that
size
cool
Danny
Nation
have you jump in next
uh yeah sure
um I just want to say
awesome kudos for still teaching
um I love it when people bring their
experiences uh in the field right to the
classroom I was wondering if you could
talk at all about you know why you chose
to keep doing that and what rewards you
see
yeah I mean if I'm being honest it
wasn't really a choice I think people
who kind of go into to teaching have a
certain personality where it's just it I
was going to be teaching wherever I was
going to be at anyways
um and I also I think I learned that way
like some people learn best through
teaching and when I have to explain
something three different ways it just
cements it my understanding of it that
much that much better in in my head
um and so I think that's the thing that
I really enjoy about teaching is like if
you know something you can always tell
when somebody really knows something if
they can explain it a bunch of different
ways if you like ask somebody to explain
something and then they say it you're
like I'm still not getting it and they
just like say the same thing over again
it's like maybe you don't get it either
like both of us I think don't get it
right but it's like if they if they can
kind of use different analogies and it's
like all right yeah I I got it so I
think that is just part of like how my
brain works and and I just enjoy you
know and interacting with people that
way too
Niall I see you have a question as well
do you want to jump in
sure thanks so uh we get pushback
sometimes for our projects not being
data sciencey enough
um and so I'm curious you know some of
the stuff you've described obviously is
is more advanced some of it sounds
fairly descriptive I'm curious
what that uh what those proportions are
and how much that influences your
decision to take on a project as a team
yeah is that pushback from from staff
people it's both it's it's both if
people are like you know that that's not
a predictive model man why are you
spending your time on that I was like
well it's what it's what was needed
right right I know I think those
conversations are easier for for me when
it's somebody pushing back and saying
like this model is not complicated
enough I'm like right can Bill you'd
support Vector machine to do what this
logistic regression does if you want me
to but
um it's going to cost you another five
weeks of work and it's gonna the r
squared is going to be just the same or
whatever and so I think that
conversation is easier the the theme
that I think
um
I really struggled with when I was
building this team so I was the first
data scientist they brought me on in
April of 2020
um and they're basically like hey we
want to do this cool data thing this
non-profit data thing am I cool what
kind of data sets do you have like we
don't have anything I'm like I'm in
Let's Do It
um and they're like who else is on my
team they're like it's just you I'm like
sweet I got it
um so as I started building the team out
I had to be really honest with people I
was bringing on board that like if
you're the kind of person who wants to
do like NLP bleeding edge tensorflow
this kind of stuff this is not the role
for you we're going to be doing a lot of
logistic regression k-means K modes uh
summary mean equals whatever
um type stuff
um and and so I just approached it by
just being really honest with them up
front I said but what I can promise you
is there's going to be a lot of impact
that we're going to make because it it's
not a cop-out to me to say
um there's so much impact that we can
make with just descriptive statistics
some summary stuff right now in this in
this sector that we're just scratching
the surface like by the time we get into
some of that advanced stuff and we are
doing some of it we've got some some
pretty big projects where we've we've
done some forecasting we've done some
some more kind of you know modeling
stuff but um
but I think that's how we've approached
it it's just been super honest about
like this isn't that role it's not going
to be a Google engineer at all
X yeah
I remember us talking about that before
in another hangout I was trying to
remember if it was Alan who was talking
about it before
um I see Adrian you had asked a question
do you want to jump in
sorry yeah I'll eating my lunch well
I'll jump in no worries I can read it
too
I'll just stay on I'll just stay off
camera let's just have to watch me chew
um
you had mentioned a handful of these
products where you're able to
uh really take advantage of these open
data packages that
seem to unlock some of the questions
that the nonprofits were asking and I'm
just curious how much of those
projects are shared if you if you if you
and your team maintain a GitHub if I'd
really like to start connecting some of
those dots myself to sort of uh
intellectual curiosity
um and I have tried to take advantage of
open uh sources in the past
and I've hit a few walls so see seeing
some that you know actually go off the
ground would be really interesting
yeah uh we do have a GitHub of course
but it is it is private to our
organization right now not not because
um we want to hoard the information but
really just because like we're just not
at a state where it's kind of messy in
there like we got some cleaning up to do
we've been going so fast uh first for a
couple years that a lot of stuff needs
to be organized and we really need to
figure out too like which pieces we're
we're able to kind of elevate to the
public
um we do have a desire to be I just put
the link to our uh Community data
platform uh didn't hyperlink for some
reason in the in the chat but um that's
kind of a public interface into our our
it's it's into the back end of the the
SQL database so go and click around
there you can see some of the sources of
the data that we're working with but the
um
the thing is there's really a couple
partitions that we have in our community
data platform there's there's what you
can see through this link which is
Census Bureau CDC all that kind of stuff
but then there's some private partitions
that you know for example Wilmington
Police Department arrests
we don't want that on the the public
GitHub or the public uh user interface
um because we have a very specific
agreement with with them that that we're
not going to do that you know New
Hanover County Schools uh discipline
reports and progress for for you know
children in public schools in the county
that's in a separate lockdown partition
of the community data platform that we
can use for some of the metrics we're
creating and some of the analyzes we're
doing but that we're not going to expose
an endpoint to to everyone else so I
think
um absolutely the in-state would love a
world in which people are kind of
pushing and pulling and and from our um
uh our GitHub and saying like we want to
add this new data set and we're like
okay here's the conventions for the data
set if you put it in this format then
you know we can add it to the community
data platform but um but we're just not
there yet
thank you so one more slido question and
it was what advice do you have for
someone who's interested in starting
their own data science consulting
company
um so I've known some people who've gone
that route and it can be very rewarding
um
I will say I
almost all of them will also tell you
though that they're able to do it for a
couple years and they got burnt out on
it and the main thing is
acquisition
um or customer uh acquisition is takes a
lot of time so I mean just kind of
pitching projects and you know you don't
realize that when you're working for a
consultancy someone else does all that
stuff someone else goes and like finds
all the contracts and says like you know
you're only seeing 10 of the contracts
that actually got pitched and signed and
executed and came to you whereas if
you're owning your own consultancy
you're the one who's got to Market and
reach out to all these things and Pitch
30 different things hoping two of them
bite
um
so I would just say like be prepared for
that part of the slog
um but you know the advantages
you know you don't you have your own
company you get to work for yourself so
yeah
okay maybe on other projects you want
maybe on a related note one last
question for you because I realize it's
already the end of our time here
um what is
one of your favorite pieces of career
advice that you've ever received or have
given
foreign
just just so many it's hard to kind of
kind of narrow it down to one but if I
I think the the biggest one is when
you're remember that the interview isn't
just for the employer
the interview is for you too
um ask those questions don't be afraid
to kind of dig deep don't be afraid to
kind of ask to can I talk to somebody
who's on the team I'll be working on and
not just my manager like somebody who's
at my level like somebody would be my
peer because I want to hear from them
um
and just really
you know make sure that it's somewhere
that you that you that you want to work
absolutely thank you so much thank you
Nick for sharing your experience and
insights with with all of us and taking
the time to answer all of our questions
we really appreciate it
yeah I really enjoyed it thank you so
much I'm gonna put my um I don't know if
there's a follow-up or anything but I
could put my uh yeah I was just gonna
say is LinkedIn the best place for
people to connect with you
um because if we want to share
that in the LinkedIn or his Link in just
a second
sorry I usually have it pulled up but it
was it wasn't quick enough on my
multitasking gear
um but I'll be sure to put it with the
recording too but thank you all so much
for the questions too have a great rest
of the day everybody